[Applause]
good rebound by curry Gillette Bowl left
open the board and the pass by Steph
Curry
white jerseys came up with it somehow
has the presence of mind to see Jonas
Jerebko they hope can fulfill that
stretch for when you get a pass with
that much space keep putting in buckets
at the right time and stop Shaw's in it
I suggest we do a job and let's get to
all the way to the rim
he's got 32
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Gary
thirty four point play
but who hit sell and they watch Markieff
Morris well then oh boy you're right
because Bradley Beal came right under
Stephon curry
[Applause]
unlimited range why isn't someone
crowding them making food on the floor I
know
[Applause]
[Music]
by hollis-jefferson dream on saving it
step hiding behind Jordan and there's
the record nobody's ever made five or
more of threes and seven games in a row
nobody's ever made five or more threes
in seven straight until right there I've
just the ball the ball goes a lot less
what binds that trailer in the round
with the stop thunder back up to a 19
point lead
Suns call it top Goodman KCET great
defense forced the turnover Williams
[Applause]
jumped off the trampoline how about the
long-playing but tears Ferguson
offensive foul will heat the screen I'm
steamed up to set a screen by split the
defense and elevates about this play saw
the space and detonates just a great
crossover mode and romances he was
trying to come over - at him and then
let's get a lot of calls just play
through it
what's good steel he's got open space
and a two-handed thunder slam this is a
[Applause]
foul Westbrook what a finish is one of
these plays where the rubber meets the
road keep the Thunder and you got to
continue to make plays like this some
turnovers there's another one nice job
by Steven Adams the long route cab Rose
gotta settle things down
Westbrook wants to try down the lane I'm
gonna give them one they will sound a
foul for Westbrook
the arefox lina seems already leaning on
that plate and this is the FA's
you wait for you have a cold drives hard
to the bucket
step-back jumper very difficult shot and
they hit ahead TLC tensed the foul and
the finish but none other the TLC know
about the hit ahead from Russell
Westbrook lamb fears back on Turkey for
the past course nut and a turnover
let's cook out of the perimeter this is
it off burden touch across and
little lazy pass yelling at himself on
the way back down the floor Westbrook
off the dribble drives the three
this first trip downtown tonight that's
what's happened here
eight consecutive
another great
spend a little to the time of the NBA
there's a greatest with that I steal
their goat in chiffon Sabrina's
[Applause]
so I swear this is good to be pizza once
again by the Thunder just starting to
take control of this boy what a pass
Westbrook slept it in in the pocket
Adams knew exactly what to do it
perhaps looking for staff
turns and fires a three
[Applause]
[Music]
I went to set the screen down to three
we've got far they push the Barry down
the lane for the
they got a mismatch
the settle furs over here so wha he
knows he could get by a bigger man
overextending was Harold too much
precious curry just used that pressure
against montrezl harrell and beat him to
the bathroom the other thing is if you
stick a jumper with seven seconds left
or something the Clippers will have an
opportunity step glint the clock this
point five he knew what he was doing but
he felt LeBron James needed some of
these veterans like Chandler and
Stevenson and Rondo around a lot of pass
drop curry and Iguodala finishes game
[Applause]
his passing can be equally entertaining
[Music]
for your defense there's 16th in the
league and efficient defensive
efficiency curry expect curry sweet blue
there from step Coco curry this summit
Acula finish and the crazy thing about
it
these are shots he works on it's not by
accident
he works on these shots 9 104 reporter
to play curry launches again
[Applause]
so let's [ __ ] with this first three of
the game you force a lot of tough shots
by the trail busy retrieval this ball
[Applause]
I'm gonna say that's nasty rough
especially at closing time passes
awesome
and he just rolls up stepping what a
sequence the weak side defender rotates
and the feathery skill to drop it in
comes curry here's a long one two down
to one his Stefan curry nine of ten
twenty three points finding should know
that he's going to take this as the
clock winds down to the halftime break
that is what he does curry fakes all
rifles a past I think it's Papa with a
little point nine remaining plays on the
offensive end Steph Curry taking the
double-team finding a wide open are
getting a dollop curry fakes two BOTS
trying to stay with him curry there it
is the first field goal
Wilt Chamberlain
well it's easy to under pre she ate
[Applause]
George as what struck house his
triple-double it comes on the playback
this year at this moment in the ballgame
and doing it at both ends leads the NBA
in steals here's curry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and he wants to drive outside Ferguson
the pass right back to Westbrook sets
the feet
[Applause]
against left this is the three that tied
it 1:16 catch fire three i like that
that catch-and-release see these posts
ups tonight for the thunder because
without Paul George they need somebody
else out for a dolphin's just like right
Felton did their for Russell Westbrook
to him you know what he is a savvy
veteran and that's one of those plays
you get you can get going off that folks
you dump it off he is so strong with
that right shoulder Thunder with a
little bit of time Westbrook charging
down the lane had the four seconds and
used almost all of it and I have to win
Defensive Player of the Year as well
Oh wicked hook another turnover it's
tried to defend curry three-quarter
court
[Music]
beats the buzzer with a Fenton 3 for his
first triple of the quarter not worrying
about his staff line gives himself a
chance good for him
I'm gonna tell you right now that's
that's the play of the game
outfit of the quarter high-risk
high-reward another consistent
inconsistent I don't really know what's
coming absolutely and it gets you the
more silly
sometimes you will get rewarded that
might be a three it is a great stuff
shrewder let it miss the follow Russell
with the loose ball they can get the
time Westbrook on the drive
[Applause]
[ __ ] it more important and then this one
right here from Toronto's perspective
[Applause]
need a couple threes there's one now you
got a foul now four seconds left you
need to do it again curry for three
that foul and they're gonna double
overtime
I think Ryan Saunders by two learned a
lesson and on it you can foul him right
there pushing it let's grab him after
stripping the balls on the floor like
that and instead curry stripes of three
oh what a clutch shot older game with
the ball in your hand yes and like JT
said it's official
Russell gets a ball [ __ ] see
[Applause]
[Music]
that's now but what he's on possibly
three years in a row is fantastic it's a
different ballgame now yeah and this is
two feet behind the three-point line so
he's definitely feeling confident he's
got his own mess right here by step in
traffic not even really looking at Katie
wants to push to the Thunder
[Applause]
it's Adams over the last couple of
possessions or deficiency I don't do
something else but I've done because
[Applause]
Stephan curry with an ode to Oracle from
way deep and a 31-point lead with his
12th rebound of the game curry long
distance that should have been a foul
let's look at Steph Curry rebound the
basketball lulls you to sleep gets to
his spot elevates that's contest that's
not allowing him to land all-time great
shooting and basketball player temple
pumping into their play by Russell
Westbrook a block from behind that's all
kinds of stuff but this is where he's
amazing he comes in gets that block from
the curry crossover three-pointer
[Music]
scratch the game plans on a finishing
results of going to Durant and curry
says Nene no no knocks down the ship
Turner guarding curry her up Co sets the
screen curry long-distance way outside
puts it in Steph Curry from downtown see
Steph Curry comes off that screen big
guy sitting further back you makes them
pay the price what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content